sur le port d'Odessa certains de ces
navires vont de nouveau pouvoir circuler
16 navires en tout devrait bénéficier
dès ce lundi d'un couloir de sécurité
grâce à l'accord conclu entre les
Nations unies la Turquie et l'Ukraine
une décision qui fait suite à l'annonce
fracassante de la Russie samedi dernier
Moscou avait déclaré sortir de l'accord
concluant sur les exportations de
céréales depuis les ports Ukrainiens
suite aux attaques contre sa flotte en
Crimée d'après les autorités
ukrainiennes pas moins 276 navires
transportant plus de 2 millions de
tonnes de céréales sont bloqués par la
Russie le président ukrainien a dénoncé
un chantage à la fin
nous sommes prêts à relâcher ce navire
dans la mer comme tous les autres qui
ont déjà quitté les ports du grand
audessa mais ce navire avec du blé pour
le programme alimentaire de l'ONU et
d'autres navires avec des produits
agricoles sont obligés d'attendre car la
Russie fait du chantage à la fin au
monde
les exportations alimentaires de
l'Ukraine qui est l'un des cinq premiers
producteurs mondiaux de céréales ont été
sévèrement réduites depuis l'invasion de
la Russie l'incertitude croissante sur
l'offre mondiale de céréales génèrent
une forte inflation de plus plusieurs
mois ce lundi les prix du blé ont
augmenté de 5,5 % et ceux du maïs de 2%
à l'ouverture des marchés